bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 78 lactu
du vendredi 14 février jour des amoureux
de la Saint-Valentin nous allons faire
le point comme tous les jours sur
l'actualité locale du département tout
d'abord en politique cette information
ce jeudi soir Robert Albert a présidé
son dernier conseil d'agglomération
considéré par beaucoup comme l'homme du
consensus Robert Cadalbert a été à la
tête de la communauté d'agglomération de
50 ans en iine pendant 16 ans pour
l'anecdote quelques chiffres au passage
au cours de ces mandats il a présidé
quelques 100 conseils d'agglomération et
comités syndicaux il a eu aussi au
passage laisser sa signature sur pas
moins de 500000 documents officiels sa
présidence aura notamment été marqué par
des grands projets comme le vélodrome de
50 ans en Eveline ou le lancement du
plateau Paris saclé selon lui la si la
communauté d'agglomération a obtenu ses
bons résultats dernièrement c'est grâce
au travail de tous je vous propose
d'ailleurs de l'écouter au micro de
Patrick jacquesed dixm la première
réussite c'est bien sûr la réussite
économique de SaintQuentin vin et et pas
pour la création de richesse mais
effectivement pour l'emploi pour le
partage de de de cette richesse au
travers de l'emploi alors il y a encore
beaucoup à faire hein la réussite de 51
V c'est d'abord la réussite d'un
partenariat même s'il a été imposé par
l'État dans l'intercommunalité au départ
c'est cette intercommunalité c'est ce
partenariat et pas simplement entre les
communes et l'intercommunité mais avec
tous les partenairire économique
associatif du territoire les habitants
c'est tout ce partenariat qui soutient
la réussite de sa an en du et Robert
Cadalbert se retire donc mais il
continuera notamment de travailler sur
la préparation de la rider Cup
quiaccueillera le Golf National en
2018 l'autre information du jour est la
décision du gouvernement con concernant
le conflit qui oppose les taxis depuis
quelques mois au véhicules de tourisme
avec chauffeur dont on a vu les grves
tout récemment Matignon a décidé de
reporter toutes les immatriculations des
VTC jusqu'à la fin de la médiation menée
avec les syndicats de taxis c'est-à-dire
précisément dans 2 mois cette nouvelle a
provoquer le soulagement des chauffeurs
de taxi l'Inter syndicale a d'ailleurs
annoncé la fin du mouvement mais dans
les Yvelines la la réaction semble
légèrement différente anonio Netto
bonjour vous êtes le président du
syndicat des taxis des Yvelines tout
d'abord quel est votre premier réaction
à cette annonce du gouvernement de gel
des immatriculations des véhicules de
tourisme avec chauffeur oui bonjour pour
ma part c'est une décision qui est sage
de la part du gouvernement qui permet
déjà d'apaiser les tensions qui
aujourd'hui sont cell des taxis V cette
concurrenceloyale par l'arrivée des VTC
par rapport à cette décision est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va aussi permettre de
de geler les VTC à l'heure actuelle ou
les véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur
ù ceuxci vont pouir continuer de rouler
et d'exercer pendant ces 2
mois non donc d'après d'après matigon
c'est un moratoire qui qui va être
maintenu pendant les 2 mois de la
négociation ce qui permettra ce qui
évitera effectivement donc la la
délivrance d'autorisation de VTC sur
territoire national pour vous c'est
seulement un moyen de calmer les
tensions on a vu beaucoup de grèves
beaucoup de d'artèr bloqué ces derniers
jours de la part des chauffeurs de taxi
oui j'espère bien que le gouvernement
enant j'espère bien que ce ce député
Monsieur Thomas tnou le médiate a bien
compris nos inquiétudes face à
l'émergence de ces nouvelles technologie
surtout sur le secteur de transport de
personne et que il va vraiment mettre à
plat la loi la loi qui régit le taxi qui
est une vieille loi qui date de de 95 et
puis essayer de trouver des règles
beaucoup plus saine afin d'établir une
concurrence loyale pour vous selon vous
cette cette médiation de 2 mois c'est
une façon de montrer et de faire un pas
envers les taxis pour essayer de
légiférer
derrière je l'espère bien parce que on
voit encore une fois on voit bien
queaujourd'hui la loi n'est plus en
adéquation avec la avec la nouvelle
technologie he la loi de kirégil taxi
c'est une loi qui date de 95 il y a eu
l'arrivée des téléphones portables et
puis encore et puis il y a plusieurs
types de de taxi le taxi ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui ce n'est qu'un lumineux qui
porte un nom mais après il y a le tax
des grandes villes qui est Paris lon
Marseille et puis après il y a le taxi
du rural un petit peu comme dans les
Ines il y a une façon de travailler qui
est complètement différente he entre
entre toutes ces toutes ces toutes ces
zones et il faut absolument que le
gouvernement éclaircisse une bonne fois
pour toutes la profession de taxi de
votre côté du syndicat des taxis des
Yvelines vous comptez du coup arrêter la
mobilisation comme l'a appelé
l'intersyndicale alors l'intersyndicale
parisienne a appelé à la mobilisation
nous il y a un préavis de mobilisation
qui est en pour l'instant maintenu pour
le 27 février très bien merci beaucoup
Antonio Netto je rappelle que vous êtes
le président du syndicat des taxis des
yvelin merci beaucoup je merci en
politique on revient à la politique
Marine Le Pen cette semaine était en
soutien au candidat tête de liste du
Front national dans le département un
déplacement remarqué ce mercredi soir
remarqué pardon ce mercredi soir au
chînet il faut dire qu' qu'en 2008 en
fait aucune liste au municipal n'avait
été déposée du côté frontiste à l'heure
actuelle 23 candidats se sont à annoncé
et neuf listes seraient déjà bouclé
c'est inespéré confesse même le
président départemental du Front
national ambiance détendue et tout
sourire ce mercredi soir enchaîné avec
la venue de la leader du Front national
une Marine Le Pen enthousiaste en 2008
au dernière municipale il n'y avait eu
aucune liste FN dans le département et
aujourd'hui 23 listes sont annoncées il
y a eu un effort absolument
spectaculaire puis qu'il y avait 0 list
en 2008 par conséquent arrivé à voir 23
têtes de liste avec déjà un grand nombre
de ces listes qui sont d'ors et déjà
bouclé c'est un très bel effort
d'implantation local c'est une priorité
hein pour le Front national c'est énorme
c'est complètement inespéré dans les
ivelines on a exactement à 100 % on
calque notre politique sur celle de
marine leopel et ça les gens le
ressentent en tout ces 23 listes
représentent 600 colistier 600 personnes
qui ont donc fait le choix de porter les
couleurs du rassemblement bleu marine
pour le département Philippe Chevrier
espère une trentaine d'élus grâce
notamment à la présence de candidats
lors de triangulaire car pas question
d'union pour un éventuel second tour
nous nous maintiendrons bien sûr au
second tour car nous voulons absolument
porter la voix du bon sens dans les
conseils municipaux et il nous apparaît
que en matière de bon sens l'UMP et le
PS ont quand même énormément de retard
sur notre secteur des candidats se sont
déclarés à Montini plaisir les clés
sous-bois et lancour reste à clôturer
les listes sur les 23 annoncés neuf
seraient bouclés les autres seraient
partiellement constitués impossible de
savoir lesquels François Siméoni à
Versailles et Philippe Chevrier à
Rambouillet eux déposeront bien leur
liste en préfecture d'ici la fin de
semaine les mauvaises annonces
continuent malheureusement pour le site
de PSA Peugeot Citroën à poissie ce
jeudi la direction a annoncé en comité
d'établissement vouloir supprimer une
des deux lignes de montage sur son site
ilinois en janvier 2015 15 mais a assuré
que cela se fera sans impact sur la main
d'œuvre de production selon ce projet
toujours à l'étude je vous le rappelle
la production de la 28 serait transféré
sur la ligne qui produit actuellement la
C3 et la DS3 et dont la cadence
augmenterait de 42 à 52 véhicules par
heure pour arriver à un taux de capacité
de production de 100 % selon la
direction dans l'usine toujours mais
pour le syndicat CGT qui a réagi via un
communiquer le passage en monoflux
signifierait tout simplement la
suppression de nouveaux postes et des
centaines d'emplois supplément à poiss
le le projet pardon du passage en
modonigne à poissie doit encore être
soumis à la consultation des partenaires
sociaux à suivre donc cette semaine une
rencontre autour de la mobilité
intelligente s'est déroulé à satori
l'occasion de découvrir les innovations
à la matière la France doit en être le
leader mondial a souligné la ministre
des le ministre des Transports présent
lors de cette journée Catherine zulato
et Patrick ja de DIM pour les
explications quel transports
intelligents pour demain le thème d'une
rencontre proposée ce mardi sur le
plateau de satori à Versailles et le
lieu n'est pas un hasard puisque c'est
ici que sera prochainement créé
l'Institut vdcom comme véhicule
décarbonés communiquant et mobilité une
fondation partenariale de l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin également
financé par le Conseil général vdcom va
être doté de moyens financiers
considérabl 330 millions sur 9 ans les
investisements d'avenir il apportent 54
millions les industriels en apportent
119 le conseil général en la porte 20
bref tout le monde s'est mis ensemble
pour constituer
un un centre de de recherche technique
de
d'industrialisation qui réunit toute
l'industrie et vous savez en France
c'est pas si facile que ça de faire
travailler les gens ensemble les
véhicules de demain qu'ils soient
électriques connectés ou automatisés un
enjeu majeur comme l'a expliqué le
ministre des Transports venu assister à
ces rencontres nous avons la chance
avoir des gens de grand talent avec des
chercheurs des découvreurs avec des
industriels avec
euh véritablement une passion des gens
passionnés et
qui croient à à leur capacité collective
à relever des défis d'une société
nouvelle et bien c'est à la fois
réconfortant et ça doit donner confiance
en l'avenir et en notre capacité parce
que c'est le cas d'être la France leader
mondiale et sur la ité intelligente la
France a pour vocation d'être leader
mondial actuellement la filière des
transports intelligents représente 4,5
milliard d'euros avec 500 à un millier
d'entreprises concernées surtout des
start-ups soit 45000 emplois
directs ce jeudi lAFPA ouvreit la porte
de ces centres de formation partout en
France si vous ne la connaissez pas
encore il s'agit d'une association qui
propose des formations pour adultes nous
nous sommes rendus à hencour un site
spécialisé dans le tertière
administratif et malgré la crise des
débouchés existent claire Cambier et
Étienne
d une journée pour changer de vie c'est
ce que proposer aujourd'hui l'fpa un
organisme de formation pour adultes
entendez par là changer de vie
professionnelle partout en France les
différents centres de cette association
ont ouvert leurs portes comme ici à
hlencour car en pleine période de crise
économique et de hausse du chômage ont
contré encore en France 300000 emplois
non pourvus quel secteur recrute quelles
formations sont disponibles sous quelles
conditions autant de questions
auxquelles Dalila et les autres
visiteurs cherchaient des réponse cette
mère de famille a arrêté de travailler
pour élever ses enfants aujourd'hui elle
peine à retrouver un emploi elle
souhaitaéintégrer ici une formation de
secrétaire assistante je reste dans ma
branche
initiale mais par contre reprend une
formation pour pouvoir être plus
performante en
informatique l'association a repéré 1
secteur d'activité sous tension de
l'industrie aéronautique et spatiale à
l'économie numérique en passant par
l'hôtellerie l'idée est donc d'aiguiller
les demandeurs d'emploi 70 % du public
de l'AFPA pour qu'ils répondent aux
demandes des entreprises la valeur
ajouté en fait des formations àpa c'est
c'est effectivement l'insertion de nos
stagiaires c'est le fait que 6 à 7
stagiair sur 10 euh soit réintégré dans
le monde professionnel la l'utilité
sociale de Lapa elle est à ce niveau-là
80 % de la formation est pratique ici
par exemple un plateau technique recrée
un domicile et permet de s'entraîner au
métier d'assistant de vie en condition
réelles en île-de-fance on compte 16
sites AFPA ouvert à tous certaines
formations peuvent être
rémunérées c'est la fin de ce 78 lactu
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
n'oubliez pas le 78 weekend avec vos
idées de sortie avec yolen Torz quant à
moi je vous souhaite un excellent
weekend à très
bientôt